And so your estimation of how rapidly this will be put into production across the industry, your meter may be a little miscalibrated. And two, I think because we work at Nvidia, we're in a bubble, and we don't realize how early things are. But like, generally, I think you are more optimistic about what current models' capabilities are. I am constantly frustrated by what current models' capabilities are, but can still get a lot done with them. And this is the reason why the C++ evolution process, it's just not competitive. Is C++, like a three-year cycle does not reflect the rate at which our industry is changing.
所以，关于这项技术在全行业投入生产的速度，你的估计可能稍微有点失准。第二，我觉得因为我们在英伟达工作，我们身处一个泡沫之中，并没有意识到事情才刚刚开始。但是，总的来说，我认为你对当前模型能力的看法更加乐观。我对当前模型的能力感到无比沮丧，尽管依然能用它们完成很多工作。这就是为什么C++的演进过程根本缺乏竞争力。C++像是一个三年的周期，根本无法反映出我们行业变化的速率。
Think about how much our industry will change in three years. So the next C++ standard will be C++29. Given everything we know about the revolution undergoing our industry right now, how can we possibly expect to get anything meaningful, out of C++ plus 29. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 301, recorded on August 12, 2026. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about my existential crisis due to AI, AI fluency, the potential death of conferences, auto-auto-rearch, and more.
想想我们的行业在三年内会发生多大的变化。所以，下一个C++标准将是C++29。鉴于我们对目前正在经历行业变革的了解，我们怎么可能指望从C++29中获得任何有意义的东西呢。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第301期，录制于2026年8月12日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起聊天，探讨我因人工智能引发的存在主义危机、AI熟练度、会议的潜在消亡、自动化自动研究等话题。
All right, I mean, should we pick up where we left off? You believe humans still needed. I am doubtful. Tell me your topic. All right, my topic, I mean, my topic is dovetails off of, you know, if we assume, you know, humans aren't really needed for coding. You know, what happens? I've been spending a lot of time thinking about this, like, post-AGI, you know, kind of world we live in. And it's the title of the episode that I had in my head, which may or may not change by the end of this recording with you, is the illusion of necessity.
好了，我的意思是，我们应该从上次中断的地方继续吗？你认为人类仍然是必需的。对此我表示怀疑。把你的话题讲给我听听。好吧，我的话题，我的意思是，我的话题紧接着，你知道的，如果我们假设，你知道的，编写代码其实不需要人类了。你知道，会发生什么？我花了很多时间思考这个问题，比如，我们所处的后AGI（通用人工智能）时代的这种世界。这就是我脑海中浮现的这期节目的标题，它可能会也可能不会在我与你这次录音结束时发生改变——那就是“必要的幻觉”。
And in a nutshell, or a larger nut with or without a shell, the idea is that I've come to realize that, like, technical conferences, technical committee meetings, a lot of stuff is just, you know, it's like that Matthew McConaughey scene from the Wolf of Wall Street. Do no, no. Where he beats his chest. It's a Fagazi, it's a Fagasy. It's all a Fugazi. You know what Fugazi is? Pugazi, it's a fake. Yeah, Fugazi, Fagazi, it's a Wazi, it's a Ferrydust.
简而言之，或者用一个带或不带壳的大坚果来比喻，这个想法是，我开始意识到，比如技术会议、技术委员会会议，很多事情其实都不过是，你知道的，就像《华尔街狼人》里马修·麦康纳（Matthew McConaughey）那个场景。不，不，不。他在捶胸顿足的那个场景。那是假的（Fagazi），那是虚构的（Fagasy）。这全都是虚幻的（Fugazi）。你知道什么是Fugazi吗？Pugazi，这就是个骗局。是的，Fugazi，Fagazi，这不过是个空谈，是仙女撒的魔法粉末。
It doesn't exist. It's never landed. It is no matter. It's not on the elemental chart. It's all just kind of, we just made it all up, you know? Do you know what I mean? It's like Microsoft, Bloomberg, all these companies that use C++, they are companies that created value for some definition of the word value for the world.
它根本不存在。它从未真正落地。这根本无所谓。它不在元素周期表上。这一切不过是，我们全都是凭空捏造出来的，你知道吗？你知道我的意思吗？就像微软、彭博社，所有这些使用C++的公司，它们是在为世界创造价值的公司，这里的价值是某种定义下的价值。
you know, they're profit generating entities, and they use C++ as a tool to generate that value. And so, you know, they started saying we should get together in person because if this is a tool that you're using to generate value, you can justify sending people to these places to meet, even if it isn't necessary. But it's like, you know, these people are creating us value. We've got to keep them happy.
你知道的，它们是盈利实体，并且将C++作为创造这种价值的工具。所以，你知道的，它们开始说我们应该进行线下聚会，因为如果这是你用来创造价值的工具，你就可以为派人去这些地方开会提供正当理由，哪怕这并不是绝对必要的。但这就好像，你知道的，这些人正在为我们创造价值。我们必须让他们高兴。
Let's send them to Hawaii. Let's send them to whatever, all over the world. and then like these changes in the language, which some definitely are good, you know, move semantics, you know, helps speed up programs, et cetera. Not all of it's bad, but you could argue that 50% of what the C++ committee does in terms of library development, which I know, you know, you were a library chair for a while. I don't mean to shoot on your past. But, you know, arguably we could have just had a package manager and called it a day, you know?
让我们把他们派到夏威夷去。让我们把他们派到世界各地去。然后就像语言中的这些改进，其中有些确实是好的，你知道的，移动语义（move semantics），你知道的，有助于加速程序，等等。并非所有改进都是不好的，但你可能会说，C++委员会在库开发方面所做的工作中，有50%——我知道，你知道的，你曾担任过一段时间的库主席。我不是故意要贬低你的过去。但是，你知道的，可以说我们本可以有一个包管理器就万事大吉了，你知道吗？
So like, it's like these meetings lead to language changes and library. standard library changes, which then lead to an ecosystem of conferences where people are meeting to do conference stuff. And it's all just like, you know, other communities evolve their languages without, you know, meeting in person. And it's just, what's my whole point is just that, like, I think the real reason that all of this stuff ends up being created is just to keep people happy. You know, there's two people that I will not name that I have an immense amount of respect
所以这就好像，这些会议带来了语言的变化和库的改变，标准库的改变，进而催生了一个会议生态系统，人们聚集在一起做一些与会议相关的事情。这一切其实都像是，你知道的，其他社区在演进他们的语言时并不需要（进行面对面的会议），你知道的，无需面对面开会。我的核心观点就是，所有这一切最终被创造出来，真正的纯粹原因其实只是为了让大家高兴。你知道的，有两个我不愿点名的人，我对他们怀有无比崇高的敬意。
for that said the C++ committee is just a social. Club. At the end of the day, that's what it is. It's people that like getting together to talk about technical stuff. And yeah, I do not, I do not disagree with that. The pandemic was a great opportunity. Ever since I joined the C++ plus committee, I found the process of language evolution to be archaic and just burdened by process and acronyms and unwritten rules. rules and guidelines and procedure. And I try my best to modernize and improve it. And we had a real opportunity with the pandemic to modernize our process, to move to
他们曾说过，C++委员会其实就是一个社交俱乐部。归根结底，它就是这么回事。它是一群喜欢聚在一起谈论技术问题的人。是的，我并不，我并不否认这一点。大流行是一个绝佳的机遇。自从我加入C++委员会以来，我发现语言的演进过程非常古老，而且被繁文缛节、各种缩写、不成文的规则、准则以及程序所累。我尽自己最大的努力去将其现代化并加以改进。而我们在大流行期间迎来了一个真正的机遇，去让我们的流程现代化，转向
asynchronous work. And a large part of the committee was like, nope, we should just shut down and not do any work during the pandemic. We can only possibly evolve this language by meeting in person. And I mean, the argument, on the other hand, is that asynchronous work. Not everybody can make time during their regular job to do asynchronous work and that there is a value to the intensity of, and the focus of everybody being in the same place at the same time, and that when you're there, you are 100% focused on the work that you're doing for the week.
异步工作。但委员会的很大一部分人却说：“不，我们应该在疫情期间直接关闭并不做任何工作。”我们只有通过面对面开会才能演进这门语言。我的意思是，另一方面也有人争辩说，异步工作并非每个人都能在日常工作中抽出时间来完成异步工作，而且大家在同一时间、同一地点聚集在一起的那种强度和专注度是有其独特价值的，当你身处其中时，你会百分之百地专注于那一周正在进行的工作。
And I do think that that is true that you do end up 100% focus for that time. However, I've never found the argument compelling that people can't make time asynchronously to work on the C++ standard throughout the year. And I think that, you know, there's a large, there's a large part of the C++ committee that, that for whom it is a hobby and not part of their day job, and those people would be disenfranchised by moving to a different process. But I actually think that was beneficial. We had too many stakeholders in C++. The people who should be making the decisions about C++ should be the people for whom working on C++ is their primary job. So the implementers and the other key stakeholders in the language,
而且我也确实认为这是真的，在那段时间里你确实能做到百分之百的专注。然而，我从未觉得“人们无法在全年抽出异步时间来致力于C++标准”这种论点有多大说服力。我认为，你知道的，C++委员会有很大一部分人，对他们而言这只是一种爱好，而不是他们日常工作的一部分，如果转向不同的流程，这部分人就会被剥夺参与权。但我实际上认为这反而是件好事。C++中的利益相关者太多了。真正应该对C++做出决策的人，应该是那些以C++开发为主要工作的人。所以也就是语言的实现者和其他关键的利益相关者，
like, that would have been better. I think that would have been a better model. But during the pandemic, there were many opportunities for the committee to modernize, and the committee rejected almost all of them. And in fact, many things, innovations and improvements that were made during the pandemic, my impression is that they have been rolled back and that now we have moved back to more or less the same process that we had beforehand,
比如说，那样会更好。我认为那会是一个更好的模式。但在大流行期间，委员会有很多实现现代化的机会，而委员会几乎拒绝了所有这些机会。事实上，许多在大流行期间做出的创新和改进，我的印象是，它们已经被回滚了，我们现在又回到了多多少少和以前一模一样的流程，
which was entirely in-person meetings. And this is the reason why the C++ evolution process, it's just not competitive. C++, like a three-year cycle does not reflect the rate at which our industry is changing. Think about how much our industry will change in three years, right? The next C++ standard will be C++29. Given everything we know about the revolution undergoing our industry right now,
也就是完全依靠线下会议。这就是为什么C++的演进过程显得如此缺乏竞争力。C++，比如一个三年的周期，根本无法反映出我们行业变化的速率。想想看，我们的行业在三年内会发生多大的变化，对吧？下一个C++标准将是C++29。鉴于我们对当前正在经历行业变革的了解，
how can we possibly expect to get anything meaningful out of C++29? Like a three-year cycle, right? Like how is the process that we've previously used for evolving C++ plus? How does that make sense when everything is changing? So no, I don't think that C++ will continue to be relevant for that reason. The length of the cycle is an artifact of the archaic process that is used to evolve C++. And there has been no, it's very hard to get people to vote to disenfranchise themselves, but that was the only way that that could have happened.
我们怎么可能指望从C++29中获得任何有意义的东西呢？就像三年为一个周期一样，对吧？那么我们以前用来演进C++的流程怎么还能说得通呢？当一切都在发生变化时，这怎么说得通？所以不，我不认为C++会因此继续保持相关性。周期的长短是用于演进C++的陈旧流程的产物。而且一直以来都没有，要让人们投票剥夺他们自己的权利是非常困难的，但那是唯一能够实现这一目标的方式。
But the industry has moved on. I don't think we, C++ does not have the same level of priority they used to have. in the barrier to entry for language compiler evolution is a lot lower now. And at least for my industry, for the compute industry, most of the interesting work doesn't happen in C++. It's a legacy language there. Most of the interesting work happens in dialects or compilers, in Python dialects or compilers. That's something we've talked about a lot on this podcast before.
但整个行业已经向前发展了。我不认为我们，C++已经不再享有过去那种优先级别了。语言编译器演进的准入门槛现在低得多了。至少对我的行业而言，对于计算行业，大部分有趣的工作并不是在C++中进行的。它在那里只是一门遗留语言。大部分有趣的工作都是在方言或编译器中进行的，在Python的方言或编译器中。这是我们以前在这个播客中经常讨论的话题。
But, like, was it all just a social club? I think there was a time in the 90s in which the collaboration model of the C++ committee was the only model that could have worked. So it literally started like at the beginning of the internet era when we did not have the tools that we had today. So no, it was not always just a social club. But the fundamental flaw was that the committee modernized C++ but never modernized itself. And that is why it has failed. So I want to separate two things here because there's the C++ committee as a, is it successful? Is it not successful?
但是，这一切难道真的只是一个社交俱乐部吗？我想在90年代确实有过这样一个时期，当时C++委员会的协作模式是唯一行之有效的模式。所以它实际上是从互联网时代初期开始的，当时我们还没有今天所拥有的这些工具。所以不，它并不总是仅仅是一个社交俱乐部。但根本的缺陷在于，委员会虽然使C++现代化了，但却从未使自身实现现代化。这就是它失败的原因。所以我想在这里区分两件事，因为这里存在着C++委员会作为一个实体——它成功了吗？它失败了吗？
We both agree. It's not going well. Not going the right direction. That being said, you know, a part of my whole existential crisis thing and realizing that a lot of the ecosystems that exist in the world, technical ecosystems, whatever, other ecosystems, you know, we've created them. And a huge aspect of them is the... social component. Whether or not you agree that like the C++ committee is like primarily a social club
我们俩都同意。进展并不顺利。并没有朝着正确的方向发展。话虽如此，你知道的，作为我整个存在主义危机的一部分，我意识到世界上存在的许多生态系统——技术生态系统，无论是什么生态系统，你知道的——都是我们创造出来的。而其中一个巨大的方面就是……社交组件。不管你是否同意C++委员会基本上就是一个社交俱乐部，
or not, you know, you can agree, disagree. But the thing that I guess it leads to my existential crisis is that I think social clubs are good, you know, whether or not they should be, you know, there's a fire truck in the background, whether or not, you know, they should be whether the C++ committee that has the task of evolving the language and the library and a lot of people, you know, there's a lot of people are paying a lot of money to fly these places. You know, as a side point, it's more that, like, there's a part of me that's, like, sad because, you know, the, I don't go to the C++ committee
还是不同意，你知道的，你可以同意，也可以不同意。但这件事——我想它导致了我的存在主义危机——是因为我认为社交俱乐部是件好事，你知道的，不管它们是否应该——背景里有一辆消防车驶过——不管它们是否应该，无论C++委员会肩负着演进语言和库的任务，而且很多人，你知道的，有很多人花大把的钱飞往这些地方。顺带一提，更准确地说，有一部分的我感到很难过，因为，你知道的，我没有去参加C++委员会的会议，
and haven't for years, for other reasons. And I still go to conferences, but are conferences going to disappear too? I think language. No, no, I actually, I said this at the Platsy Conf in Mexico. It was actually a very interesting talk about mentors and sort of my career journey and how to volunteer and get involved in tech communities. One of the points I made there was that in the current age where every internet,
而且由于其他原因，已经好几年没去了。我仍然会去参加会议，但会议也会消失吗？我认为语言。不，不，实际上我在墨西哥的Platsy大会上说过这个。那其实是一个非常有趣的演讲，关于导师、我的职业心路历程以及如何做志愿者并参与到科技社区中去。我在那里提出的观点之一是，在当今这个时代，每一个互联网、
social media platform and forum is filled with AI generated content, I actually think that there is a higher value placed on in-person events because it's a higher value placed on in-person events because it's more genuine. It is hard to fill. The signal to noise ratio on social media platforms, on online communities is a lot higher than it used to be. And so if you're getting started in this industry, how are you going to make connections on the internet?
社交媒体平台和论坛都充满了人工智能生成的内容，我实际上认为线下活动具有更高的价值，因为线下活动具有更高的价值，它显得更加真诚。这很难填补。社交媒体平台和在线社区上的信噪比比过去高得多了。因此，如果你刚开始进入这个行业，你打算如何在互联网上建立人脉呢？
I think it's harder than it used to be, and I think that there is still a great value in local events and in conferences. And one of the points I made is like, yeah, if you want to get started in tech, it is important to have a network. And the best events are the events that you can get to. So you don't necessarily need to go to a big conference if you can find a conference or a meetup in your community. And if there isn't one, you can start one. But I do think that these have a great value, maybe even even. more of a value than they had in the post-pandemic pre-AI era.
我认为这比以前更难了，而且我认为本地活动和会议仍然具有巨大的价值。我提出的观点之一是，是的，如果你想在科技界起步，建立一个人际网络非常重要。而最好的活动就是那些你能去参加的活动。所以你不一定非要去参加一个大型会议，只要你能在自己的社区里找到一个会议或聚会就行。如果没有的话，你还可以自己发起一个。但我确实认为这些活动具有巨大的价值，甚至可能，比大流行后、人工智能时代之前的价值还要大。
To a certain extent, I agree. I guess the part I'm worried about is like... Hang on, every time you're talking, you've got to say that again, you broke up. I've got my recursive self-improvement agent running, though. But we can start it up again once I... What is it recursively self-improving? Well, I figured I've got my little colonel agent program and, you know, I'm trying to get it to improve. And I just figured, I was like, you know what, why don't I just put my loop inside a loop and tell it to improve itself?
在某种程度上，我同意你的看法。我想我担心的是……等等，每次你说话的时候，你都得重说一遍，刚才断信号了。不过我的递归自我改进智能体正在运行。但等我……它到底是怎么个递归自我改进法？嗯，我想我有我的微型内核智能体程序，你知道的，我正试图让它不断改进。我当时想，你知道吗，为什么我不直接把我的循环嵌套在另一个循环里，然后告诉它去改进自己呢？
Yeah, that's, I've been, I've been looking at doing that, at doing auto research. Yeah, I've been looking at that recently. This is like auto auto auto research, though. Yeah, yes, that's, that's specifically what I've been calling it is auto auto research. Yeah. It's very compute intensive, though. Yeah, I haven't cracked it, cracked it the code perfectly yet, but it is very colorful to look at. Anyways, I mean, the question is, it's like, you know, there are conferences that I want to go to because it's fun.
是的，那是，我一直在，我一直在考虑这样做，去搞自动研究。是的，我最近一直在研究这个。不过这就像是“自动自动化自动研究”了。是的，是的，这正是我一直称呼它的名字：自动自动化研究。不过这非常消耗计算资源。是的，我还没完全把它搞懂，还没完全破解代码，但它看起来确实五光十色、挺有意思的。总之，我的意思是，问题在于，有些会议我是想去的，因为很有趣。
But, you know, I feel like I should be careful with the words that I say, you know, because it's not like I don't want to get, like, I don't want to be uninvited from conferences and stuff, but I just, I don't see the value in going to a C++ conference or going to. Oh, yeah, I haven't, I haven't, I haven't been to a C++ conference in a while. I'm going to a Gentic conference. Yeah, but that's the thing. So I was going to say, like, insert any programming language conference, really, is like, I just, yeah, I don't, I don't really see the value from a, like, technical perspective. Like, I could make that argument two, three years ago, and it's also enjoyable to go to the conferences, but now I'm just like, if it's not AI-related, but then it's kind of sad because then, like,
但是，你知道的，我觉得我在说话时得小心谨慎，你知道的，因为我可不想被，就像我不想被取消会议邀请之类的，但我就是，我看不上去参加C++会议或者去参加……哦，是的，我已经有一段时间没去参加C++会议了。我要去参加一个智能体（Agentic）会议。是的，但就是这样。所以我想说的是，真的，插入任何一门编程语言的会议都一样，我只是，是的，我从技术角度来看，真的看不出有什么价值。两三年前我或许还能那样辩解，去参加会议也确实挺令人愉快的，但现在我只觉得，如果它跟人工智能无关，那就有点让人难过了，因为那样的话，
you're you're kind of like not abandoning a community you were a part of and this is like the whole like I feel like I kind of bouncing back and forth and not coherently making my point but like I think the community is like super important is it was one of the outcomes of my existential crisis is that like being a part of a community whether it's technical whether it's like friends and family it's very important it's like it's like part of the essence of being human in my opinion if you don't have like a community it's like that's what leads to depression or I'm sure like one of the things that contributes to depression. And so like to be in this moment where for a while I was going to either functional conferences
你多少有点像是在，不能说是抛弃一个你曾属于的社区，这就是那种整体的感觉——我觉得我有点反反复复，没有连贯地表达我的观点，但我想说的是社区超级重要。这是我的存在主义危机带来的结果之一，那就是成为一个社区的一部分——无论是技术社区，还是朋友和家人组成的社区——都非常重要。在我看来，这就像是身为人类本质的一部分。如果你没有一个社区，那就，这正是导致抑郁的原因，或者我相信这是导致抑郁的因素之一。所以，在这样一个时刻——有一段时间我一直在去参加函数式编程会议，
or C++ conferences or Python conferences and then realizing that like there's a huge shift in the industry that I work in, which is now kind of like rendering those communities. Like it sounds harsh to say obsolete. But like that's kind of how it feels a little bit. like and anyways it's just coming to turns that's why like i said like the illusion of necessity like was it even necessary before not really but like you can justify meeting up because it is good for continuous learning and it's very it's very healthy to like especially if you're a remote no i i still i still get a ton of i still got a ton of value out of interacting directly with
或者C++会议，或者Python会议，然后突然意识到，我所工作的行业正在发生巨大的转变，这使得那些社区现在看来……说它们过时听起来可能有点刺耳。但感觉确实有点像那样。无论如何，这只是接受现实的过程，这就是为什么我说“必要的幻觉”——以前真的有必要吗？其实并没有，但你可以为聚会找到正当理由，因为这有利于持续学习，而且非常健康，特别是如果你是远程办公的话。不，我，我依然，我依然从直接与
our with like users and with tech communities at conferences but like you said you said you started going to agentic conferences now. Not C++ conferences. Yeah, but like I still go to Python conferences. I'll probably still go to some rest conferences. Like the events I've gone to changed a bit, but, and like the focus has changed. Like, I used to go
我们的用户以及会议上的技术社区进行互动中获得了巨大的价值，但就像你说的，你刚才说你现在开始去参加智能体会议了。而不是C++会议。是的，但，我还是会去Python会议。我可能还是会去一些Rust会议。我参加的活动确实发生了一些变化，而且重点也变了。比如，我以前去
to conferences to go for the talks. Now I go almost exclusively to, like, talk to people. But like, I, I don't know, I may, I may, I may go to less events in the future just because I feel like it's cutting, like, I feel like I have more to do as an IC
会议是为了听演讲。现在我几乎完全是为了去和人交流。但我想，我，我不知道，我以后可能会减少参加活动的次数，因为我觉得这在削减，我觉得作为一名IC（独立贡献者），现在有更多的事情等着我去做，这种感觉比很长一段时间以来的任何时候都要强烈，这让我觉得更有影响力，我想花更多的时间去做这些事，我不知道，我出差的频率也占用了这部分时间，所以我可能会——我已经推掉了今年剩下的部分演讲邀约，我以后可能会减少出差，所以，快跟我聊聊吧——因为我知道你参加过一些Python活动，你都去过哪些智能体会议？你被邀请去这些会议上做过演讲吗？你申请在这些会议上演讲过吗？我去了GOSM。我去参加了在巴黎举办的GOSM。我还听说过在波兰举办的Agent Conf。我可能还会去参加另一个GOSM。外面有好多这样的会议。有很多都在涌现。我不知道到底哪几个
contributor now than I have had in a long time and that feels more impactful and I want to spend more time doing that and I don't know that and the amount of travel that I do cuts into that so I may like I've turned down speaking opportunities through part of the rest of the year I may I may do less travel in the future so like rattle off to me because I know you were at a couple python events like what are the agentic conferences you've gone to and like have you been invited to speak at these? Have you applied to speak at these? I went to GOSM. I went to GOSM Paris. There's Agent Conf that's in Poland that I heard about. There's another GOSM that I might go to. There's a bunch of these conferences out there. There's a bunch popping. I don't know which ones
现在比很长一段时间以来的任何时候都更有贡献感，这感觉更有影响力，我想花更多的时间在这上面，但我不知道而且我目前的差旅量影响了这一点，所以我可能会像拒绝了今年剩下时间里的演讲机会一样，我未来可能会减少出差，所以请跟我连珠炮似地说说，因为我知道你参加了几个Python活动，比如你去过哪些智能体（agentic）会议？你是否被邀请在这些会议上演讲？你申请在这些会议上演讲过吗？我去了GOSM。我去了巴黎的GOSM。我知道波兰有个Agent Conf。还有另一个我可能会去的GOSM。外面有很多这样的会议。有很多会议正在涌现。我不知道有哪些
are like necessarily the most popular. There's like the Pi Torch conference, the MLSys, like ICML, like all the big AI conferences. Like I think those ones are still like, you know, super important and relevant to go to. And like you do also have to keep in mind that like, Like, we're still very early in the AI era. And it's going to be, like, this is an industry that moves very slowly and is a lot of inertia. And, like, yeah, like, things are moving fast now. But if you look at, like, adoption, like, adoption is still relatively slow. And, like, I continue having conversations with people.
才一定是最受欢迎的。比如PyTorch大会、MLSys、ICML，所有这些大型的人工智能会议。我觉得这些会议依然（你知道的）非常重要，非常值得一去。而且你也必须记住，人工智能时代我们其实还处于非常早期的阶段。这将是一个发展非常缓慢、充满惯性的行业，而且，是的，现在事情发展得很快。但如果你看看，比如采纳率，采纳率其实仍然相对缓慢。而且，我一直在和人们进行交流，
Like, one of the biggest takeaways I have from going to conferences is talking to people and realizing the disconnect between where I am on AI. and where other people are on AI. I did this thing that I may try to turn into... So I have a vision. So I... Let me take a step back. I don't know how to teach CUDA anymore
我参加会议最大的收获之一就是与人们交谈，并意识到我在人工智能所处的位置与其他人对人工智能的理解之间存在着脱节。我做了一件事，我可能会尝试把它变成……所以我有一个愿景。所以……让我退一步说。我不知道该怎么教CUDA了，
because I, for the last 18 months, have, like, been the person maintaining and developing a lot of the CUDA educational content that's on NVIDIA's Accelerated Computing Hub. Like, I rebuilt all of our CUDA Python stuff from the ground up. I sort of took on the maintenance of the CUDA C++ stuff that our colleague Georgie maintained, and I've sort of been the steward and shepherd for this content. I've been doing a lot of teaching and training sort of prior to the long horizon, agentic revolution at the start of this year.
因为在过去18个月里，我一直是那个维护和开发英伟达加速计算中心（Accelerated Computing Hub）上大量CUDA教育内容的人。比如，我从头到尾重建了我们所有的CUDA Python内容。我某种程度上接手了我同事乔治（Georgie）维护的CUDA C++内容的维护工作，并且我一直是这些内容的管理员和引路人。在今年年初那个漫长地平线上的智能体革命之前，我一直在做大量的教学和培训工作。
And then since that start of that revolution, my interest in focus on the educational content has decreased a lot because it just feels so outdated, like popping up a Jupyter notebook and having people like type code into it. And so I did this thing at EuroPython and Eurocypi sprints that was kind of impromptu. And I have to give a big thank you to Modal. Model is a serverless GPU provider. So they provide GPU compute for inference, for training, and also for like sandboxes and notebooks. And so instead of you like renting a GPU node for where you're charged per hour or whatnot, they let you like spin up a GPU environment where you can like run one function on a GPU. And they have this checkpoint and restore thing.
自那场革命开始以来，我对教育内容的兴趣和关注大大减少了，因为这感觉太陈旧了，比如弹出一个Jupyter Notebook然后让人们把代码敲进去。所以我在EuroPython和EuroSciPy冲刺编程（sprints）期间做了一件临时起意的事。我必须对Modal表示巨大的感谢。Modal是一家无服务器GPU提供商。所以他们为推理、训练以及沙盒和笔记本提供GPU计算资源。因此，你不用去租用一个按小时计费或其他计费方式的GPU节点，他们允许你启动一个GPU环境，你可以在GPU上运行单个函数。他们拥有这种检查点和恢复功能。
So like you can run one function and then like go do other stuff and then go run another function later in the same environment. And what they'll do is they'll cache your environment somewhere and then they'll restore it later and they can restore it very, very quickly in a matter of milliseconds or something like that. Anyways, modal people were at EuroPython and I basically propositioned them. on like Friday morning for a pile of credits to go do this sprint and they were able to get me set up very quickly, which I greatly appreciate. And what I did for the sprint is a prototype of what I'm going to call Auto Research Academy. And our listeners may or may not know about GPU mode. GPU mode is this kernel coding, this kernel, GPU kernel programming community. And they regularly run these GPU kernel coding competitions. And one of the reasons to run these GPU kernel coding
所以你可以运行一个函数，然后去干别的，之后还可以在同一个环境中再次运行另一个函数。他们会把你的环境缓存到某个地方，随后再恢复它，而且他们可以非常非常快地恢复它，只需几毫秒左右的时间。不管怎样，Modal的人当时在EuroPython现场，我在周五早上向他们提出了一项关于赞助一些额度来举办这次冲刺编程的提议，他们非常迅速地帮我搞定了一切，对此我非常感激。我在冲刺编程中做的是我称之为“自动研究学院”（Auto Research Academy）的原型。我们的听众可能知道也可能不知道GPU mode。GPU mode是一个内核编程、内核、GPU内核编程社区。他们经常举办这种GPU内核编程比赛。举办这些GPU内核编程比赛的原因之一是，
competitions is that they are a great way to generate high quality data on what good GPU kernels look like and what optimizing new kernels look like. And that data is very useful for people that want to go and train models to be better at writing Kuta code. And the kernels themselves can be very useful. Some of the kernels generated by this coding competition. So this training data, or this data from GPU mode can be very valuable. One, the kernels themselves are very valuable. Some of the kernels developed for these coding competitions have influenced things that have gone into open source libraries or in video products. The data itself is published openly and people can use it when they're doing research on developing new open models or using it in their model
它们是生成高质量数据的绝佳途径，这些数据关于优质的GPU内核应该是什么样子的，优化新内核的过程是怎样的。对于那些想要训练模型以更好地编写CUDA代码的人来说，这些数据非常有用。而且内核本身也非常有用。这次编程比赛产生的一些内核。所以这些训练数据，或者来自GPU mode的这些数据可以非常宝贵。第一，内核本身就很有价值。为这些编程比赛开发的某些内核已经影响了进入开源库或英伟达产品的功能。数据本身是公开发布的，人们在开展开发新开源模型的研究时可以使用它，或者在模型训练中使用它，以使他们的模型在编写GPU内核方面表现得更好。但是，我们在夏天举办了一系列比赛，GPU mode举办了一系列比赛，这些比赛都集中在这些线性代数内核上，即QR求解器、乔列斯基（Cholesky）求解器和特征值求解器。
training to make their models better at writing GPU kernels. But so we did a bunch of contests, the GPU mud did a bunch of contests over the summer, and those contests were all focused on these linear algebra kernels, so QR solvers, Chilleschi solvers, and eigenvalue solvers. And one of the competes was ongoing during the EuroPython and Eurocypy sprints. So the premise of the sprint was you're going to come and learn how to compete in these contests. And you don't need to know anything about GPU programming.
其中一场比赛在EuroPython和EuroSciPy冲刺编程期间正在进行。所以冲刺编程的前提是：你来学习如何参加这些比赛。你不需要了解任何关于GPU编程的知识，
because what you're going to learn is how to set up an agentic loop to compete in these contests, so how to do auto research. So no GPU knowledge is required. And I just gave people, you know, an inference key for Nvidia's inference hub. So I just like set up an inference key for seven days. And I just, you know, told people, just go wild, do whatever. And we had, I think, eight or nine people show up in total. and the sprints are over course of two days,
因为你要学习的是如何建立一个智能体循环来参加这些比赛，也就是如何进行自动研究。所以不需要任何GPU知识。我只是给每个人（你知道的）发了一个英伟达推理中心（Inference Hub）的推理密钥。所以我只是设置了一个为期七天的推理密钥。然后我（你知道的）告诉大家，尽管放手去干，随心所欲地做吧。我们总共来了八、九个人，
and it was absolutely amazing. Some people had never done any GPU programming before at all. Most people had never used AI in this way. They had maybe used cursor. Some of them had used Claude Code or some form of agent, but nobody had done long horizon tasks. Part of the reason for that is because, you know, it's expensive. a lot of these people were using their own personal subscriptions, or some of them were telling me,
冲刺编程为期两天，绝对太棒了。有些人以前从未做过任何GPU编程。大多数人以前从未使用过这种方式的AI。他们可能用过Cursor。其中一些人使用过Claude Code或某种形式的智能体，但没有人做过长期视角的任务。部分原因是因为，你知道的，这很昂贵。许多这些人都在使用他们自己的个人订阅，或者他们中的一些人告诉我，
yeah, we're not allowed to use AI at work at all. Like, you know, I've used it for some personal projects, but we're not allowed to use this in work, so they've not really had a chance to use it in anger. And this is one of the reasons why, like, I specifically wanted to give them access to, like, unrestricted access to a variety of frontier models, because I wanted people to have the experience of what you do in that setup. And I gave everybody a sandbox and the inference keys and then we had these modal credits and I just let people go wild. And I think that I tweeted about it that like every like we had four or five people who sort of got working loops up and running and submitted like placed in the
是的，我们在工作中根本不被允许使用AI。比如，你知道的，我在一些个人项目上用过它，但我们在工作中不允许使用这个，所以他们真的没有机会在实战中使用过它。这就是为什么我特别想让他们能够不受限制地访问各种前沿模型的原因，因为我希望人们能够体验到在这种设置下你会做些什么。我给每个人提供了一个沙盒和推理密钥，然后我们有了这些Modal的额度，我只是让大家尽情发挥。我想我在推特上说过，我们有四、五个人建立并运行了正常工作的循环，并且提交了代码，
the between top 10 and top 20. Ironically, some of the people who did best, were some of the people who had the least knowledge about CUDA. And I attribute that in part to unguided versus guided, that the people who knew about CUDA were more likely to guide the model, to say do a specific thing to keep the human in the loop, versus the people who had no knowledge about CUDA had no option but to do something unguided. But everybody did really well.
排名在第10到第20名之间。讽刺的是，表现最好的一些人，反而是对CUDA了解最少的人。我将此部分归因于“无引导”与“有引导”的区别，那些了解CUDA的人更有可能去引导模型，要求模型做特定的事情，让人类保持在循环中（human in the loop），而那些对CUDA一无所知的人除了采取无引导的盲目做法之外别无选择。但每个人都做得非常好。
Everybody had submissions, like everybody who stayed for both days, had submissions on the leaderboard. And a lot of, I think it was very, rewarding for everybody involved. And I came away with that, with this idea that like, okay, this is how you would teach Kuda programming going forward. And that's where the idea for Auto Research Academy comes from. And the way I would do Auto Research Academy is as follows. So it would be two hours a day in the morning at like a week-long conference like GTC. And instead of being a tutorial, it would be more like a study group. So you come and meet for, two hours in the morning or so. And part of it is set up in teaching you, okay, we're going to, here's how we do our agentic loop. Here's the problem that we're trying to solve. It would be some sort of GPU mode like problem that everybody would be competing in. So some part of it would be set up, getting everybody onboarded. You would get access to inference. You would get access
每个人都有提交的代码，所有坚持了两天的人，都在排行榜上有提交记录。而且我认为，这对所有参与其中的人来说都是非常有收获的。我带着这个想法离开了，那就是：好吧，这才是你以后教授CUDA编程的方式。这就是“自动研究学院”这个构想的由来。我开设“自动研究学院”的方式如下。这将是类似GTC这样为期一周的会议上，每天早晨两个小时的课程。它不会是一个教程，而更像是一个学习小组。所以你来聚在一起，
to compute. You'd get access to sandboxes so that you could play around with this. And then the other part of this two hours every day would be a lecture, but the lecture wouldn't be on coding. The lecture would be on theory and system fundamentals. Like, have somebody like Stephen Jones give a lecture on like the basics of Kuta of like how a GPU works. Or like on the next day, have somebody give a lecture on the math behind the particular problem that we're writing a kernel for. but none of the lectures would have anything to do with code. They would all be about the theory. And as the week goes on in the mornings, you know, you would basically, you'd come in and sort of,
每天早晨开会两个小时左右。一部分内容是教你：好的，我们将要，这里是我们如何构建智能体循环的方法。这里是我们试图解决的问题。这将是每个人都将参与竞争的某种类似于GPU mode的问题。所以其中一部分将是完成设置，让每个人都上手。你将获得推理权限。你将获得计算权限。你将获得沙盒权限，以便你可以围绕这些进行尝试。然后这每天两小时的另一部分将是一个讲座，但讲座的内容不是关于编码的。讲座将关于理论和系统基础。比如，让史蒂芬·琼斯（Stephen Jones）这样的人来做一个关于CUDA基础知识的讲座，讲讲GPU是如何工作的。或者在第二天，让某人做一个讲座，讲解我们为其编写内核的特定问题背后的数学原理。但所有的讲座都将与代码毫无关系。它们都将关乎理论。随着早晨这一周的推进，你知道的，你基本上会走进来，
it would be a check-in on like, how are things going? What problems have you had? Because in between each two-hour study group session, your agents have been working on in doing stuff. And so when you'd come to check in, it would sort of be your time to like report in on your progress and like chat with people who might be able to help you if you're run into some weird problem or something. And yeah, this is, this is, I think, the future of how I would teach Kuda. Yeah, I would, if I, I will pitch the idea for GTC 2026. I already know, I already know, like the five speakers that I would have speak. And that would be a pretty great lineup.
这就变成了一个签到环节，看看进展如何？你遇到了什么问题？因为在每次两小时的学习小组会话之间，你的智能体一直在努力工作并做着各种事情。所以当你来签到时，这就成了你汇报进展的时间，并与那些可能在你遇到某些奇怪问题时帮到你的人进行交流。是的，这就是，我认为这就是我以后教授CUDA的未来。是的，我会的，我会把这个想法提交给GTC 2026。我心里已经有数了，我知道我会邀请哪五位演讲者来做演讲。那将会是一个相当棒的阵容。
It was, it was really something else. Like, you know, we had some students who come. And, you know, the thing is like you think like oh but if the agent's doing all the work like what do they learn well just people couldn't be more wrong about that because i guarantee you if i had pitched a sprint of like come write kuda kernels half of those people wouldn't have shown up because it would have been too intimidating but instead i specifically said you don't need to know this because we're just going to learn how to automate it and yeah like they didn't write the code themselves. But after the two days, on the second day, when people started having results, we started talking about, like, okay, how do we analyze these results? And like, what's the actual
这真的是不同寻常的体验。比如，你知道的，我们来了一些学生。而且，事情是这样的，你可能会想：“哦，如果智能体在做所有的工作，那他们能学到什么呢？”人们对此简直是大错特错，因为我向你保证，如果我当时发起的是一个“来编写CUDA内核”的冲刺编程，那些人有一半都不会出现，因为这太让人望而生畏了。但相反，我明确地说：“你们不需要懂这个，因为我们只是要学习如何将其自动化。”是的，就像他们没有自己写代码一样。
problem that we're solving? Like, what's the math behind the problem that we're solving? And, like, what does a good solution look like? And, like, what is your agent doing versus your agent? And we started, like, looking at, like, okay, well, you know, to understand why this worked, then you need to understand this piece of how GPUs work. And then I would show them this is how this aspect of GPU programming would work. And sort of like, because they, it was their agent, they felt like an ownership of it, you know, and they felt motivated to try to understand what it was doing. And so, like, instead of learning by doing something yourself, you have the agent do something and then you, the human, had to try to figure out what did it do? And did it do? And did it do?
但在两天后，在第二天，当大家开始有了成果时，我们开始讨论：好的，我们如何分析这些结果？我们真正在解决的问题是什么？比如，我们正在解决的问题背后的数学原理是什么？一个好的解决方案应该是什么样的？你的智能体和别人的智能体有什么区别？我们开始研究：好吧，你知道的，要明白为什么这起作用，你需要了解GPU工作原理的这一部分。然后我会向他们展示GPU编程的这个方面是如何工作的。由于那是他们自己的智能体，他们对它产生了一种主人翁感，你知道的，他们有动力去试图理解它在做什么。因此，与其通过自己动手做某事来学习，不如让智能体做某事，然后由你——人类——去找出它到底做了什么。它有没有做
do something valuable and like, why did this work and why did that not work? And through that process, I think those people learned more about CUDA than they would have in other settings. And they also learned a more valuable skill than writing CUDA kernels. They learned how to automate writing CUDA kernels and then how to evaluate the results of that automation. And that is the skill I would want to teach people going forward. So yeah, like I think I would delete all of the current way that we teach and that this is what I would teach going forward. Yeah, it's funny that you've had this whole thought exercise because I've not in the exact same articulation,
有价值的事情？为什么这个方法管用而那个方法不管用？通过这个过程，我认为这些人对CUDA的了解比他们在其他任何环境中学到的都要多。而且他们还学到了一项比编写CUDA内核更有价值的技能。他们学会了如何自动化编写CUDA内核，以及如何评估该自动化结果的好坏。这就是我今后想要教给人们的技能。所以，是的，我认为我会废弃目前所有的教学方式，而这就是我今后要教的内容。是的，真搞笑，你竟然经历了这样一番思想演练，虽然我的表达方式不尽相同，
but once again to come back to the existential crisis, I've been thinking like if programming languages don't matter, like all of the insights and valuable things I feel like I have to talk about are like in that space. And then I was even talking to my wife, Shima. I was like, you know, like, sure, okay, you find a new AI community or whatever, about like what am I going to talk about and and then she made me realize that like I don't think that like what I now call like AI fluency is what do you call it like I don't think I have anything
但再次回到存在主义危机，我一直在思考，如果编程语言根本不重要，那么我觉得自己必须谈论的所有见解和有价值的东西都在那个领域。然后我甚至和我的妻子西玛（Shima）交谈过。我说：“你知道的，好吧，你找到了一个新的AI社区什么的，那我到底要谈论什么呢？”然后她让我意识到，我觉得——我现在称之为“AI熟练度”的东西，你管它叫什么呢——我觉得我在那方面没有什么好说的，但事实真相是，大多数人甚至连接近具备AI熟练度都谈不上，而你和我都是具备的，这本身就是……这正是你所描述的——把人们放在这些智能体面前，然后进行为期一周的工作坊。
to say there but the truth of the matter is is like most people aren't even close to being like AI fluent and like both you and I are and that itself is like and that's what you're describing right like putting people in front of these agents and then having a workshop over a week. And then, like, you don't realize, like, how much you've internalized how to use these things well. And, you know, that, I'm not going to go start, like, a company called, like, AI Fluent, you know, Academy.
然后，你没有意识到，比如你已经内化了多少如何很好地使用这些工具的方法。你知道的，我不会去创办一家叫做“AI熟练度学院”的公司。
But, you know, if I were going to go do something, like, it would be an idea, right? Because it's like, on one hand, you're correct that the adoption rate of the larger industry outside of tech, but just like the white collar spreadsheet intellectual work has adopted this stuff very slowly. On the other hand, though, I think that it's going to like, it's going to be like a tidal wave of disruption way faster than people think. Because if you're a company that doesn't adopt this stuff, you're going to be displaced by a new competitor that is operating this way because it's just impossible to compete. And yes, the large Microsofts, and sales forces and whatever,
但是，如果我要去做点什么，那会是一个好主意，对吧？因为一方面，你的看法是正确的，科技行业之外的更大行业的采纳率——不仅仅是白领阶层处理电子表格的知识性工作——采纳这些东西的速度非常慢。但另一方面，我认为它将像狂潮一样以比人们想象的快得多的速度带来颠覆。因为如果你是一家不采用这些东西的公司，你将会被以这种方式运营的新竞争对手所取代，因为根本无法与之竞争。是的，像大型的微软、
they're still going to have the way that they operate, but just like, I don't think in five years, like the landscape is going to look anything remotely close to like what it looks like right now. I think it's going to be, I think it's going to be a,
Salesforce以及其他公司，它们仍然会有它们的运营方式，但只是，我不认为在五年内，整个格局会与现在看起来的样子有任何相似之处。我认为它将是，我认为它将是……
I think the long tail is going to be a slower journey than you might think. I think that it's going to be a long time before it's saturated. I mean, it was, honestly, it was the most valuable part of Euro Python and Euro SciPy for me,
我认为长尾效应的发展历程可能会比你想象的要慢。我认为需要很长一段时间才能达到饱和。说实话，这对我来说是EuroPython和EuroSciPy中最有价值的部分。
was this experience. And just the degree to which folks had not tried this before. And like I'm constantly running into people who have not tried or have not had the opportunity to try before and who I push to give it a shot. And then I check back in on them three or six months later. And they've, their workflows have changed. And like in part because I convinced them to try.
这段经历就是这样。大家以前没怎么尝试过这种技术，而我经常遇到一些没试过或没机会试的人，我会鼓励他们去试试。三六个月后我再去了解情况，他们的工作流程已经变了，部分原因就是因为我劝他们试了试。
And I just think it's going to take. a longer to drive adoption than you might think. I think that this, this, the frontier will continue advancing, but the frontier is a small group of people. And in, in right now, it is very expensive to try stuff out. Like, I do think, I do think to get good at this, you've got to make a couple $10,000 mistakes. And not everybody has the budget to make $10,000 mistakes. And that's not going to be true in two to three years, because the frontier intelligence of today will get more commoditized. And the, like, Opus 4.5 level intelligence, maybe like Opus 4.8 level intelligence, is really good enough for a lot of these long horizon tasks. Like, those are the
而且我觉得，要推动这种普及，花费的时间可能会比你想象的要长。我认为这个前沿领域会继续推进，但前沿只是一小群人。现在，尝试新东西的成本非常高。我的意思是，我觉得要想精通这个，你得交几万美元的学费。并不是每个人都有预算去犯那些价值一万美元的错误。两三年后情况就会不同了，因为今天的尖端智能会变得更加商品化。像 Opus 4.5 级别的智能，或者说 Opus 4.8 级别的智能，对于很多这种长周期任务来说，其实已经足够好了。就像那些
models starting like January, February of this year are the models that really unlocked long horizon tasks, which have been the big game changer. And those capabilities will get commoditized and token prices will go down as new hardware comes out, as new open models come out, token prices will go down and it will not always be the case where you have to make a few $10,000 mistakes to really learn how to use this stuff. But at least right now, you've got to make a couple $10,000 mistakes to learn how to use this stuff. I do think there's a huge value to giving people an environment in which they can make those mistakes in not $10,000, but maybe $1,000 mistakes in an environment where they can, they can feel like they can experiment without having fear about the repercussions of failure. And I think that's one of the problems that people have right now is that either they don't have
从今年一月、二月开始出现的模型，才是真正解锁了长周期任务的模型，这才是巨大的改变。随着新硬件的推出、新的开源模型的出现，这些能力将会商品化，Token 价格也会下降。以后不会总是需要犯下价值几万美元的错误才能真正学会如何使用这些东西。但至少在现在，你必须犯下几次价值一万美元的错误才能学会使用它们。不过，给人们提供一个环境，让他们在那里犯的不是一万美元、而是一千美元的错误，这绝对有巨大的价值。在一个让他们觉得可以放心实验、而不必害怕失败后果的环境里，我觉得这是人们现在面临的问题之一：要么他们没有
access to tokens and frontier models or they do have access, but they're afraid to make those big mistakes. And even you, even you were afraid. I don't worry about my inference bill that much because... Oh, I thought I was going to say I was just afraid of making mistakes. I was like, what are you talking about? But the... Yes.
获取 Token 和前沿模型的渠道，要么他们虽然有渠道，却害怕犯那些大错。甚至连你，连你也害怕。我其实不太担心我的推理账单，因为……哦，我本来想说我只是害怕犯错。我当时想，你在说什么呢？但是……是的。
You were afraid of your inference bill, right? Yes, and still am, but... Yeah, I'm at... Let's see, I'm checking right now. The last few days has made it worse. Let's see. Why is location not Berlin? Why is this a filter on the AI spend
你确实害怕你的推理账单，对吧？是的，现在还是，但是……对，我现在……让我看看，我正在查。这几天情况更糟了。让我们看看。为什么地点不是柏林？为什么 AI 支出仪表板上有个默认开启的筛选条件，
dashboard, that there's a filter that's on by default, that is location is not Berlin. 1.3 billion cursor tokens, 50.1 billion cloud code tokens, 63.9 billion codex tokens, and then 256 billion tokens on our internal inference hub. So that is 256 plus 63 plus 505,000, one. So let's say it's 370 billion tokens that I've spent year to date, which is a lot.
上面写着地点不是柏林？13 亿 Cursor Token，501 亿 Cloud Code Token，639 亿 Codex Token，还有 2560 亿 Token 是在我们内部推理中心消耗的。所以是 2560 亿加上 630 亿再加上 50 万左右，呃，一个。总之，可以说我今年迄今为止已经消耗了 3700 亿 Token，这非常多。
It probably puts me in the top, I don't know, the top hundred of spend it, NVIDIA, probably. But, but like there's stuff that I've learned in that process that I don't think I could have learned without doing things at scale. Like, certainly I've made mistakes, but if I didn't make those mistakes, how would I have known that they were mistakes? You know? If I didn't go and try stuff, how would I have known? And there's certain behaviors that only emerge, like, at scale. And, like, there's certain stuff that only happens, like, when I'm 100 hours into an auto research loop. And there's just, there's no way to get 100 hours into an auto research loop without spending a couple billion tokens.
这可能让我排在英伟达支出的前一百名左右吧。但是，在这个过程中我学到的一些东西，我觉得如果不进行大规模的实践是绝对学不到的。当然，我犯过错误，但如果我不犯这些错误，我又怎么会知道那是错误呢？你知道吗？如果我不去尝试各种东西，我又怎么会知道呢？而且有些行为只有在规模化的时候才会显现出来。有些事情只有当我进行长达 100 小时的自动化研究循环时才会发生。如果没有消耗几十亿个 Token，根本不可能让自动化研究循环运行满 100 个小时。
Anyways, we got to cut everything we just talked about for the last 20 minutes. And how do we wrap up this episode? Because I probably need to go soon. How are we wrapping up this episode? I don't know, man. It started off, this wasn't the episode I thought it was going to be. What did you think this episode was going to be? I don't know.
总之，我们刚才聊的过去 20 分钟的内容全都得剪掉。那我们怎么给这一期节目收尾呢？因为我可能很快就得走了。我们到底该怎么收尾？我也不知道，老兄。一开始时，这并不是我想象中那种节目。你以为这期节目会是怎样的？我不知道。
Like I said, it started off as existential crisis, conferences, committees, Fagazi, Fagasy. and then we started talking about being AI fluent in like auto research. I'm going to diagnose you. I think you have two problems. One, I think that because you are, you're in the research side of things, you've not been exposed to like the difficult, like the challenges with like deploying this stuff and scale that other people have. And so your estimation of how rapidly this will be put into production across the industry, your meter may be a little miscalibrated.
就像我说的，它一开始是个生存危机、各种会议、委员会、虚头巴脑的东西，然后我们开始讨论对 AI 的熟悉程度，比如自动化研究。我要给你诊断一下。我觉得你有两个问题。第一，因为你身处研究领域，你没有接触到其他人所面临的、关于部署这种技术的困难和规模化挑战。因此，你对这项技术在整个行业中被投入生产的速度的估计，可能有点失准。
And in two, I think because we work at Nvidia, we're in a bubble, and we don't realize how early things are. But generally, I think you are more optimistic about what current models' capabilities are. I am constantly frustrated by what current models' capabilities are. but can still get a lot done with them. So I think that the current models are not as good as you think they are, and not as many people are using them as quickly as you think they are. So the skills that you have are still valuable.
第二，我觉得因为我们在英伟达工作，我们身处一个泡沫之中，没有意识到事情还处于多么早期的阶段。但总的来说，你对当前模型能力的看法过于乐观了。我对当前模型的能力一直感到很沮丧，但依然能用它们完成很多工作。所以我觉得当前的模型并没有你想象的那么好，也没有像你想象的那么多人、那么快地在使用它们。因此，你所拥有的技能依然很有价值。
I also think that understanding the theory and the systems behind software is a more valuable skill now than it has ever been in this industry. This is maybe the only time that a CS degree is actually, may be really helpful because for strategic decisions a human is still going to be involved. And so like understand like your knowledge of algorithms, your knowledge of like programming language theory, like all those things are still going to be valuable in how you direct and use agents. I don't know.
我也认为，理解软件背后的理论和系统，在当今这个行业里比以往任何时候都更有价值。这也许是计算机科学学位真正、可能确实非常有用的唯一时期，因为在战略决策中，人类仍然会参与其中。因此，你对算法的了解、对编程语言理论的了解，所有这些在指导和使用智能体时依然很有价值。我不知道。
I think that like the fifth interview of the classic DSA data structures and algorithms interview where you did four algorithms and data structures, and then the fifth one was large-scale system design. I think the large-scale system design is the thing that's really important. But like knowing the different flavors of like chunk-by, chunk-by-key, you know, partition, stable partition. I don't know, ma'am. I hope I'm wrong, but I think, you know, I don't know.
我觉得经典的 DSA（数据结构与算法）面试中的第五轮面试，也就是你做了四轮算法和数据结构之后，第五轮是大型系统设计。我觉得大型系统设计才是真正重要的东西。但是了解那些按块、按键分区、稳定分区的各种细分变体……我不知道，老兄。我希望我是错的，但我觉得，我不知道。
I don't think that stuff is that useful. I think that knowledge of like minutia of like language syntax and stuff like that is less useful. But like knowledge of like systems, knowledge of like performance, like all of that is valuable. And field experience is valuable. And so I don't think that like, I don't think that your experience is any less valuable because anything that you're experienced with, you're going to be better at figuring out how to automate it well than other people are. Time will tell.
我觉得那些东西没那么有用。我觉得了解语言语法等琐碎细节的知识用处较小。但对系统、性能的了解，所有这些都是有价值的。行业实地经验也是有价值的。因此，我不认为你的经验有任何贬值，因为凭借你熟悉的经验，你会比其他人更擅长弄清楚如何很好地将其自动化。时间会证明一切。
And also, like, you also have to keep in mind, like, somebody has to figure out how to train these models and build these models and make them good at coding. And people who have skills like you and I do are probably uniquely well suited to work on those sorts of things. Just wait. Eventually, eventually you're going to get a little further down the road and start getting into, like, the RL and Eval's side of things. I mean, yeah, we got Nemotron. You know, I'm not worried about my employability. I'm more worried about just society. Nothing, nothing important, nothing big.
而且，你还得记住，总得有人去想办法训练这些模型、构建这些模型并让它们擅长编写代码。像你和我这样拥有技能的人，可能极其适合从事这些方面的工作。等着瞧吧。最终，你总会更进一步，开始涉足强化学习（RL）和评测（Evals）这方面的事情。我的意思是，对，我们有 Nemotron。你知道的，我不担心我的就业能力。我更担心的是整个社会。没什么大不了的，没什么大不了的。
Just society as a whole, you know. What are your concerns about society? I thought you were concerned about our society of like the field of suffering. I can't help you with your concerns, your existential concerns about the impacts on society. I can't help you with the impacts of this on, you know, our industry. Oh, no, I mean, I'm going to, we're going to be fine. We're good to go. I mean, I mean more...
就是整个社会，你知道的。你对社会有什么担忧？我还以为你担心的是我们这个充满痛苦的领域。对于你对社会影响的担忧、那些生存危机，我帮不了你。对于这项技术对我们行业的影响，我也爱莫能助。哦，不，我的意思是，我们会没事的。我们好得很。我的意思是说……
And what are you worried about? Like I said, I just think like a ton of communities... Well, I've realized, like I said, by my existential crisis and it's just that, like, I think a lot of the motivation for certain meetings and whether it's a conference or a committee meeting was like, it's actually social. It's not actually technical. And you can justify it with technical talks. but it's really a social thing.
那你到底在担心什么？就像我说的，我只是觉得一大堆社群……好吧，我意识到了，就像我由于生存危机所意识到的一样，很多会议或委员会会议背后的动机其实是社交性质的，而不是真正技术层面的。你可以用技术演讲来为它辩解，但这其实是一件很社交的事。
But why is that a problem? Why is that a problem? Because you're not going to be able to justify it. There's no technical justification anymore. And those communities and conferences are going to... You're telling me that while our field undergoes a massive revolution that changes all aspects of software engineering, that continued education is not going to be something that companies are going to prioritize?
但为什么这是个问题？为什么这是个问题？因为你以后没法为它辩解了。再也没有技术层面的正当理由了。那些社群和会议将会……你是说，当我们的领域经历一场彻底改变软件工程方方面面的巨大革命时，持续教育不会成为公司优先考虑的事情吗？
not at the types of conferences that we have historically gone to I think that all of those conferences are slowly gonna like all of those conferences are going to either go away or they're going to have more and more than that's what I mean you just said it you just said it they're going to go away that is the point I think I think that the majority of them AI will become a part of those conferences because it will become a part of the whole industry
在那种我们过去常去的那类会议上不会了。我觉得所有那些会议都会慢慢地……所有这些会议要么会消失，要么会有越来越多的……这就是我的意思，你刚才也这么说了，你刚刚说过它们会消失，这才是重点。我觉得其中大部分，AI 将成为这些会议的一部分，因为它将成为整个行业的一部分。
the the software development and AI-assisted software development will become one in the same. It's like, you know, there's talks about, like, package management at CPP-Con. Like, people talk about, like, version control and branching strategies, right? Like, it's a C++ conference, but people still talk about, like, software engineering, and AI is going to become inexplicably linked with software engineering. I guarantee you, if you go look at the agenda for any C++ conference, like, A good chunk of the talks are going to be talking about AI and vibe coding and code review and the challenges of using AI for particular language.
软件开发和 AI 辅助软件开发将合二为一。就像在 C++ 大会上总有关于包管理的演讲一样。人们会谈论版本控制和分支策略，对吧？它虽然是一个 C++ 会议，但大家仍然在讨论软件工程，而 AI 将与软件工程密不可分。我向你保证，如果你去看任何 C++ 会议的议程，其中很大一部分演讲都会讨论 AI、Vibe 编码、代码审查，以及在特定语言中使用 AI 所面临的挑战。
It's everywhere, man. The conferences are going to adapt. Maybe. And if they do, I don't think it's willingly. I get the sense that, like, the world hates AI. You are correct that there is a large part of the world that, yes, you're correct about that. There's a large part that is afraid. even within our industry.
到处都是，老兄。会议将会适应。也许吧。如果它们真的适应了，我也觉得它们不是心甘情愿的。我有一种感觉，那就是全世界都讨厌 AI。你说得对，世界上很大一部分人确实……是的，你这话没错。很大一部分人感到害怕，甚至在我们行业内部也是如此。
There's a large part that don't like it, and it does centralize power to some degree. And I do think that big tech benefits more than smaller tech companies. And in particular, if you're a software freelancer, if you work at a smaller company, you just have a lot fewer resources, a lot less access to resources than other people do,
有很大一部分人不喜欢它，而且它在某种程度上确实将权力集中化了。我确实认为大型科技公司比小型科技公司受益更多。尤其是如果你是一个软件自由职业者，或者你在一个小公司工作，你的资源就要少得多，获取资源的渠道也比其他人少得多，
and that's going to be tough. But eventually this technology will commoditize and will be more widely available. I mean, just imagine, Connor, if you will, what happens when the token prices go down 100X? When the stuff that would cost us, you know, $1,000 today costs, you know, $10. It's going to be game-changing. I mean, it already is game-changing. Yeah, but, but, like, once doing like a billion token task costs like $10, not $1,000,
这将会很艰难。但最终这项技术会实现商品化，并变得更加普及。我是说，康纳，如果你能想象一下，当 Token 价格下降 100 倍时会发生什么？当今天需要花 1000 美元的事情只需要 10 美元时。这将具有颠覆性意义。我的意思是，它现在就已经具有颠覆性了。对，但是，一旦做一件消耗十亿 Token 的任务只需要 10 美元，而不是 1000 美元，
then like everybody's going to be able to do the stuff that we're doing. And that's really when the like, wait, the thing that I think you, you think you don't realize how early we are. I think AGI is right around the corner. We are, as Demis Hasabas said, former head of GDM, Google Deep Mine. Now I think he's head of alphabet. They promoted them. We are in the foothills of the singularity.
那么每个人都能做我们正在做的事情了。而这才是真正让人觉得……等等，我觉得你没有意识到我们还处于多么早期的阶段。我认为通用人工智能（AGI）就在拐角处。正如前谷歌深度思维（Google DeepMind）负责人德米斯·哈萨比斯（Demis Hassabis）所说——现在我想他是 Alphabet 的负责人了，他们给他升了职——我们正处于奇性（Singularity）的山麓。1
And you may think we're, early and probably for tons of corners of industries. You know, it is early, but I think coding is dead. And maybe this should just be episode 300. We were going to, we were planning on bringing on a special, no, no, no, no, no, no, because come on, because we got, we got to do a Sean episode for episode 300. All right, so this will be episode 301 then, so, you've already heard the Sean episode. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP, the podcast.
你可能会觉得现在还很早，对于行业的许多角落来说，确实还很早，但我认为编程已死。也许这就该是第 300 期节目。我们本来打算邀请一位特别的……不，不，不，不，不，因为拜局，我们得为第 300 期节目做一期肖恩（Sean）特辑。好吧，那这就将是第 301 期节目了，所以，你们已经听过肖恩特辑了。请务必查看节目shownotes，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 adsp the podcast
podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
podcast.com 上，都可以找到今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下你的想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这根本不是我们的标语。我们的标语是“洒满信息 sprinkles 的混乱”。这一期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。